[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADNAN BEGOVIC: For
those that don't know,
here is a brief little
Wikipedia entry.
We're essentially a
derivative operating system
based off Android.
We add other features, but we're
mostly free and open source,
and we score 160 plus devices,
verses Nexus AOSP program,
which is about five devices.
Our contributor base
is massive, as you can
see this Cid head over here.
Every single line in there
is a name of contributor
over the past five years.
In total we have about
1,253 contributors,
that's as of August, with
about 47,000 commits.
That's not [INAUDIBLE], so
it's quite a large delta.
But essentially what we
do is crowdsource Android
development.
We get community changes
that are incoming.
We roll them into our
nightly release builds
and those actually ship on
devices every single night.
Today, however, we're
going to be talking
about how this delta
grew a little too large
and became a little
bit unmanageable.
First we're going to be talking
about our TreeHacks Hackaton
learnings.
We went to Stanford hackathon.
We learned a lot of things that
we were a little bit ignorant
about.
We realize that OS and
firmware development
is really intimidating.
There's a lot of
work, few awards
and essentially we came
up with a solution that
could help us get through it.
ROMAN BIRG: So TreeHacks
was a weekend long
hackaton back in February
and that was at Stanford.
So there was like 670
kids who attended.
And you could imagine there
were some smart guys there.
There's applications from
all over the United States.
So we had two guys submit an
entry using the CyanogenMod
platform, and we went there,
and that's what we tried to do.
We wanted to get
people to hack on it.
And so we had two entries.
Here is the winner,
CyanTranslate.
And these guys built--
they went from synching
the source, to building it,
to adding a whole new feature
in three days.
And we learned that
that's a lot to do
and a lot to absorb in just
a short amount of time.
So these guys had
basically just one day
they spent trying
to get the source.
We bought some hard drives
to make it go by faster,
but CyanogenMod source
is 25 gigabytes.
It's going to take some time.
And then they spent the next
day getting familiar with it,
with the build system,
trying to figure out
the different quirks.
And they didn't have that
much time left to code.
They didn't need
it, to be honest.
And that said something to us.
So overall we had a great
time helping the kids,
getting it set up.
But we noticed that
most the time we
weren't helping them with
very Android specific things
that we were there for.
We helped get them set
up with the build system
and just weird little
quirks and things like that.
So this is their project.
I hope it pays.
So what these guys
did was they came up
with an on-the-fly translator.
They hooked into CyanogenMod,
and they hooked it up
to Google Translate.
And so it works
from the MMS app,
and they're going
to show you how
it works from the web browser.
And they do this in
the span of one day.
So we got a lot of feedback from
these guys, and it was great.
They love the open platform.
They love that they could just
go and contribute to our Gerrit
and see all of the submissions,
and everything's on GitHub.
They can go see.
They can go look at the code.
We even have some documentation
that helped them get started.
But it wasn't enough.
But some of the
downsides that we saw
was that it took them way
too long to get started,
and that's something
we took to heart.
We want to fix this.
It's a huge codebase
that's 25 gigs of source,
then you have another
50 when you're building,
and then there's
100 plus packages
that you just have to look
at, and it's a ton of code.
And the thing is
the barrier of entry
doesn't have to be that high.
And we really tried.
We took this feedback
heart, and we went
and we asked ourselv-- we came
up with these questions on how
do we improve this experience.
We wanted to decrease
the barrier to entry
to allow these kids
to not have to have
all this tribal knowledge
of how the platform works
to submit a feature.
We wanted to help
streamline the process
and formalize it on how
people contribute to us.
And also we wanted to stabilize
our own interfaces inside.
Like, if we wanted to use
our own features we could,
but what if the
versioning is changed?
And what if we change something
on the device we shipped,
and our code didn't--.
We didn't have these things
figured out quite properly.
So this is the moral of story.
OS development is intimidating.
If you've ever managed to
include a fully functioned
interface, you'd be one
of the few people who
understood the process from
a full stack perspective.
And that's a hard thing to do.
So one of these biggest
features in CyanogenMod
was the Profiles contribution.
So Profiles was added
by Martin Long in 2014.
And Profiles-- you
could essentially
register for specific
events in the system,
and then you could configure
your device to react to them.
So, for example,
here's an example
of a user creating an action
to be triggered by an event.
So specifically the event being
a Wi-Fi SSID connect event.
So from the Settings
app, the user
is setting up on the Wi-Fi
connect of their choice.
When the SSID connects, they
hit the Profile Service.
The Profile Service
tells the system,
hey, when this
Wi-Fi SSID connects,
send it back to
the profile system,
and the profile will
trigger the actions back
that user has selected.
So could my app have
used this Profile System?
No, not without weird
crappy Java reflection,
which we try to
avoid as much we can.
For the Android
compatibility documents,
they say that any public method
in Android namespace that
is not part of the
Android-- public API
must be marked the
@hide annotation.
ADNAN BEGOVIC: So the dreaded
@hide-- @hide essentially
is just Javadoc annotation,
specific to Android build 10.
the way it works
is any methods you
don't want the public
API you annotate
them with @hide and
then during compile
do they get stripped
from the API stubs.
It gets stripped
from the Javadocs,
and essentially it's only
accessible via reflection
during runtime, if you're
creating interfaces that way,
which is bad practice,
I guess, for us.
What implications that had for
us, something like Profiles.
If we wanted to
extend that to, let's
say, applications we were
working in separate teams
or with someone externally.
We couldn't actually
do that because there'd
be no stable interfaces.
I couldn't tell you that,
hey, you make this API call,
you'll get this result
back, because we
didn't have any explicit
versioning at that time.
We also made QA a really
horrible experience
because we couldn't set
any testing expectations
based on versioning releases.
And then, honestly, just
horrible rebase conflicts.
Every single time a
new version of Android
came out we'd have to
go and replay all the
commits that created the
service and everything that
came on top of it.
Just became way too much .
So with that we kind
of sat down and said,
how do we get around this.
So we came out the
CyanogenMod platform.
So it's a new, more
approachable infrastructure.
And the way it works is
we duplicate the Android
framework.
So we essentially have three
components here-- the platform
library, a secondary
resource package,
and then a statically
linkable SDK.
The platform library essentially
hosts all the system services
that we get spun up by the
system server, within Android.
So pretty much anything
that does state management,
like the Profile
Service, or anything
that we need to rely on being
there and interacting with,
is hosted and lives here.
We're just leveraging Android's
powerful IPC framework
for that.
Secondary to that, we also
have a resource package.
So if ever we want to just
even have a system where we're
going to reuse
across applications,
we now have a very
specific identifier
we can query those resources
with, or drawables,
or anything in between.
We'd also declare
our own permissions
that we carry on forward
without platform releases.
But the biggest point
here is the platform SDK.
So this essentially
a jar you can just
toss into your project.
These are the stable
interfaces that
can invoke the
system binder calls,
and you'll actually have
access to these features.
And this actually goes on
a rolling release schedule.
So we take this new platform
and we go back to back
to the hackathons.
Recently, we actually
did another event
that's done by IDEAA,
it's called Code Rush.
And then we went down to
Mountain View for Hack
the Planet, which--
really smart kids there.
Came up with a lot
of cool projects.
And our feedback was a
lot different this time.
It's consumable.
And ease of use
gets tossed around.
Our bottlenecks ended
up just being logistics.
So we didn't enough
CM devices there
we didn't have
emulator images, which
we're working on currently.
But one such contribution we
had from one of the interfaces
we added is we allowed the
user-- or the developer
now-- to create tiles
programmatically.
And one team who is creating
a QR code application--
essentially a bitcoin
wallet-- they said,
it would be great if I didn't
have to go access my app
and go to all of
my account settings
and go find this QR code.
So essentially they just
publish their QR code
to the Quick Settings panel,
go in the expanded mode
and anyone could scan it.
So it's things like this
so we can allow now.
Roman's going to cover
how to actually utilize
the SDK in your app.
ROMAN BIRG: So utilizing
it is actually--
I had a good
experience trying it
the first time after
everything was in place.
It was just as easy
as I had hoped.
So all you do is fire up Android
Studio, start up a new project,
and you're ready to go.
So we have our version 2.0,
which is our stable release
right now, the SDK.
And to compile against that
version you would include
the compile
'org.cyanogenmod:platform', you
hit version 2.0.
We are on a rolling release.
The next version
will be 3, so if you
want to work against our
development branches,
you can set that up
in your bulid.gradel,
and now you can use the SDK.
All you have is define the
dependency in your build.gradle
and Maven will pull
it down, sync it,
and you can hit our SDKs.
So I'm going to jump
right into the code here
of how to add a custom tile.
So this works very
similarly to how
you would post a notification.
So when you when you click
on a notification and intent
gets fired, the
first thing we do
is we need a pending
intent to wrap it.
And you can see I'm
creating a new intent there
with a custom action that
I'll be listening for later on
and I can respond to.
Then I use the custom tile
builder to create the tile.
I give it the label, the icon.
I tell it I want it to
collapse after I click it
for my specific use case.
And then the last
thing is I can just
tell the CMStatusBarManager
to go, hey publish this tile.
I give it a unique
identifier within my app
and it will show up.
On the other end, responding
to the click of the tile,
you define that listener
in the AndroidManifest
that listens to the action
which I defined in the intent
in the previous slide.
And then in the
code all it's doing
is it just removes itself.
You can come up with
whatever you want.
Use your imagination.
There's so many
things you can do.
Now I want to bring this
back to the profiles.
So CyanogenMod chips with
three profiles by default.
There's an automobile
one, a default one,
and the silent profile.
I usually set my car up
to automatically switch
to the automobile one when it
hooks up to my car Bluetooth.
But I wanted it to
do something more.
Like sometimes in the
car I want an icon
to show up so I don't have to
go digging through all my apps.
Like maybe I want to open
Google Maps or something.
So to do that you can listen
for profile state changes,
and you get sent this
intent which is in our SDK.
You listen for the profile
selected intent and then
when I receive that I know
the profile has changed
I'm going to act upon it.
In the code you'll
notice how similar this
looks to the other
side and I wanted
it to be just that simple.
All we do is we check if
the car profile is active.
If it is then publish my
car custom shortcut tile.
If it's not then
it gets removed.
It's just as simple as that.
ADNAN BEGOVIC: Going
back to how did
we deal with creating
a versioning system.
So we kind of decided to
mirror the entire build class
from Android.
If you're familiar checking
API levels programmatically,
this is one to one from that.
Essentially what we're querying
is an SDK integer that's
exported as a system
properties from the file
system in your
current environment
or whatever device
you're running on.
And you can create against
a hard coded API level
to see feature's available.
So this way we can
actually check like hey,
are we running on a
CyanogenMod device at all.
And if we're running
on a CyanogenMod device
there's an API
level that's greater
than when this was introduced,
and that essentially
allows us to interact
with the Profile Service.
Currently we're on API level
two as our stable release, which
is called Boysenberry.
We have a lot of features
actually included in there,
and we continuously
add a lot more.
Every single quarter we will
publish documentation on this,
and currently we also host
full Java docs on GitHub.
Contributing is still
very much similar
to how it's always
been to CyanogenMod,
and it's very core
and fundamental
to how our AOSP has worked.
You essentially repo
init the main manifest.
You pull it down,
repo synch it, and you
start your local changes.
You can contribute
it back to us,
and we actually put this in
a little bit more scrutiny
than we do other code,
mostly because we
want to retain
the compatibility,
mostly in terms of CTS.
For those unfamiliar, CTS is
a certification testing suite
that Google has you
run to make sure
that you can actually get GMS
services and things like that.
So we make sure that all those
interfaces are stable before we
even look at your code.
We'll actually ask you
to write unit tests.
We'll pretty much have
you put in all the legwork
to make sure that your
contribution is stable.
Then if it does get
included in you'd become
part of the rolling release.
And then at the end
of the quarter usually
your future gets included.
We actually had a
guy from Portugal--
he's very big into multisend.
At this time Marshmallow
was not released.
So he wanted to
have multisend APIs.
So he pretty much wrote
his entire interface
so his application could
talk to his own interface
that he created in
the operating system.
And he actually released his
app on the Play store recently,
and he contributed that
full interface to us.
But for now, I'm going to open
up the floor for questions
if anyone's got some.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: When will
the custom file
data guys support rich content?
ADNAN BEGOVIC: When
they will support what?
AUDIENCE: Rich content.
ADNAN BEGOVIC: Oh, rich content?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ADNAN BEGOVIC: You know more
than the people in this room.
ROMAN BIRG: Work in progress.
ADNAN BEGOVIC: So on a
staging branch right now
we have a pretty cool
feature that essentially lets
you render an or external
processes surface within a view
container in your hierarchy.
So it lets you actually
get like rich content.
If you wanted to render a
map view from another app
or get that bound
into your view argue,
it's actually something
we're actively working on.
Good.
ROMAN BIRG: So I put up
some samples for my code
that I have.
It'll actually run.
It'll actually publish a
title that you can play with.
The link is down
there-- the bit.ly link.
And the CM SDK, it's got a wiki.
I encourage you to go there.
Wiki, API links.
It's got great documentation.
I highly encourage you
guys to go check out.
ADNAN BEGOVIC: Thank
you guys for coming out.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]